hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
before we begin we wanted to cover a few
housekeeping items
for any common technical issues please
refer to the help widget located at the
bottom of your screen
if you have any questions during the
webcast you can submit them through the
q a widget
questions will be answered immediately
following the presentation
any resources and links provided from
today's presentation can be found in the
resource list
an on-demand version of the webcast will
be available approximately one day after
the webcast
and can be accessed using the same
audience link that was sent to you
earlier
let's get started
so uh welcome to the day on advanced
lectures i'm alek khagruwal and together
with john
uh we'll talk to you today about some of
the foundations underpinning
applications of reinforcement learning
to real world problems
now you've probably heard about
reinforcement learning recently it's
been
in the news a fair bit for a variety of
reasons some of the
probably most uh popular successes have
come from various
game domains whether it's in board games
like go
video games like dota starcraft
or even multiplayer settings like poker
there have been other cases such as
the recent result on solving rubik's
cube using a
robotic arm and other manipulation tasks
of that flavor
there have also been notable
applications in
real industrial settings where
reinforcement learning is now being
deployed
such as for making uh various kinds of
personalized recommendations
uh for doing um for for controlling
autonomous systems whether it's
things like sale planes and drones or
large-scale cooling systems however i
have to
say that um industry applications still
remain fewer and further
in between then we think about sort of
applications of machine learning in
industry at large
uh to the to the point that actually
some of our efforts in this area
uh in building out a service which
enables easier deployment of
reinforcement learning and
products was in fact recognized recently
by an award by
acm special interest group on artificial
intelligence
because reinforcement learning is not
that widely being industrially used yet
so what we'll try to do uh through the
through this hour today is
talk to you about uh the opportunities
as well as challenges
in trying to apply reinforcement
learning to real-world settings
and i'll use this running example to
both illustrate concepts and
various structural structural
assumptions we'll need at different
points of time
and there's a pretty simple uh example
so we all have dust jobs
sometimes maybe it's good to take a
break
a very short break and do some physical
activity
and there's a variety of apps that you
could
use that based on some um
long-term health goals that you might
set would try to give you
a a good exercise recommendation to you
if you're going to take a short break
like should you uh do some crunches did
you
should you do some squats should we just
like do a lap around the office or
something right so
so so you have um any of these uh
possibilities you you could choose from
so let's think about
uh what the process looks like from the
point of view of that app right so
uh it probably senses something about
the current state of the user
maybe you know how when did you have
your last meal
what time of day it is um
what's maybe your if we are getting any
kind of
um monitoring data what's your current
heart rate pulse etc and based on all
these
uh it might suggest some activity that
might be beneficial to you and
monitor some sort of outcome such as the
number of calories you burned the number
of steps you walked or something right
and really the goal here is to optimize
some sort of long-term health goals of
the user
that could be weight loss that could be
maintaining your sugar levels if you're
a diabetic
helping you sleep better at night and so
on right so
this is what i've described to you so
far is a
pretty typical process
underlying a generic reinforcement
learning problem so let's let's
let's annotate it with some of the
terminology that comes up in the area
that's going to be useful for us
throughout the stock
so the first thing we observe this user
state
is usually uh called a context or state
in the reinforcement learning parallax
and
we we observe this object then we
make a decision or choose an action
we'll use these two words
interchangeably
and upon making this choice
the world reveals some sort of reward to
us indicating whether this choice was
sort of good and bad but really this uh
the the reward we observe here like the
calories burned is just sort of an
imperfect
indicator imperfect proxy on how
uh how well our choices are doing
towards meeting the longer term health
goals right so we don't just
care about uh the calories burned at one
given
exercise routine we we care about
how well we are doing towards these
longer term
health goals which uh which we get an
imperfect window
of through these rewards off right
so now we can now now that we've uh
realized these uh more general concepts
we could take the example
and really put it in a more abstract
setting
where we have an interaction between a
world and an agent
the agent starts by sensing the current
context of the world
now based on this context
it would like to choose an action right
like the
activity recommendation and this mapping
which goes from a context to an action
is called a policy it's a it's the
agent's behavior policy
so the agent has an underlying policy
which it uses to decide
uh what to do observes a reward
and this process repeats over and over
again
right so that the every uh if if in the
activated recommendation example the the
user is hopefully using this app
over an extended period of time and
there are many many users of the app so
so that that's that's why these
the this interaction process repeats
and the goal is to find a policy that
maximizes kind of the sum of rewards
over time
right so so that that that's that's how
we think about long-term goals
it's not just the reward we obtain at
one particular round but we want to
uh optimize the overall sum of rewards
we get over some extended period of time
and if we can enable this
this generic loop it turns out it can
have
a broad range of many disruptive
applications so you've already mentioned
uh personalized recommendations which we
are already
uh seeing deployed people are excited
about
a variety of applications in education
and health domains
um in optimizing all kinds of uh
things related to resource allocation
configuration of network parameters and
so on so
all kinds of interesting problems in
computer systems
in large scale autonomous systems like
drones ccs and so on
the gaming indus industry really seems
ready for a big disruption with
again using these reinforcement learning
agents to develop
better game ai better developer tools
and so on
now one thing you might be wondering as
i'm talking to you is
um well machine learning is having
already such a big impact
in in the industry why do i need this uh
reinforcement learning thing right and
um i would like to take a minute to
contrast
uh what we typically think about uh
machine learning which is supervised
learning
uh with what we think about in
reinforcement learning right and i would
like to call out the distinction between
two two
uh related but very different quantities
one is a prediction and one is a
decision
right so supervised learning like uh
like doing
object recognition recognition like
doing ocr
like doing speech recognition these are
all um
prediction problems right we we we see
something
and we try to predict what it contains
and in our data sets we get some sort of
ground truth about whether we made the
correct prediction or not
and sometimes doing that prediction is
really the task you care about
but oftentimes a prediction is just uh
something
along the path to helping you make
better decisions
in uh some application right so let's
think through what the distinction looks
like
for instance if we are in recommendation
settings we might try to predict
something like
whether a user is going to click or not
uh on on a
displayed recommendation but that's not
what we actually care about we just care
about
making good recommendations to users
right so
we might only try we might try to
predict this quantity
but that's just on the path to making
good recommendations
in a conversational system you might try
to predict the user's intent from the
conversation snippet you've seen so far
but really what you would like to do is
you would like to predict
the next utterance the agent should take
in order to
result in an overall useful conversation
similarly if you're optimizing the the
let's say
if you're trying to do cache
optimization you might be trying to
predict something about
how the queue size is going to behave if
you allocate things a certain way
but that's not what you actually care
about what you actually care about is
how you route
right so in all of these things the
prediction is not the actual
thing that that the problem wants you to
do well on
you you want to be able to make good
decisions
and what's useful is if you start
thinking about the decisions directly
rather than the predictions
that you're making along the path
there are several uh benefits you start
to witness
so one is uh when we think about um the
error in our predictions
well we might have certain errors that
have actually no
real impact on the reward the agent
gets because we might be making sort of
uh prediction errors in cases where it
does not matter or between choices which
have
equally good reward uh when when we take
those actions
in the real world right so if we
directly reason about our decisions and
the rewards we get
by making those decisions we can
do much much more
much more informed trade-offs
one of the things that we're going to
talk about in just a moment is thinking
about
the types of decisions we are making
makes us worry about the quality of data
we have
um and in particular gives rise to this
exploration
issue that we're going to actually hear
a fair bit more about today
and really this type of reasoning i
would say is is a key ingredient in
designing adaptive learning agents that
sort of learn as they interact with the
world and improve over time which is
something that
we would all like to see i hope for a
variety of reasons
now doing this does not come easy so
definitely when we go from
go to reinforcement learning there are
some additional challenges
that we have to solve which are not
necessarily present
in uh standard uh supervised learning
right so
the the first one which is common
between reinforcement learning and
supervised learning is that we would
like to have good generalization
right so it's not like we have uh uh we
have
um so so in the in this example if you
think about
just one specific user then when each
time they come to the app
they probably have slightly different
combinations of you know the calories
they've consumed so far
the the their heart rate and uh
how how good they how well did they
sleep last night and so on right
so even it's not like the the
the context of a user that the system
senses
is identical over time almost all
interactions have different contexts
and we cannot hope to reason across them
separately
we need to generalize across the various
contexts the same way you don't say
you you don't try to do ocr by like
reasoning about each particular squiggle
somebody might put on the paper
separately you try to generalize across
them
however there are some additional
challenges you get
right so remember note here that when we
recommend an activity
we only get to observe the reward
outcome for the activity recommended we
don't know what would have happened
if we recommended something else so
there is no notion of like a ground
truth label that we are getting
and this is this is the part where we
only
so we only get to observe the quality of
the action we choose and this is what
necessitates what's called exploration
we have to try
uh different choices and only that
that's only how we learn about them
and finally there is this part about you
observe something in the short term but
that's only a proxy
for what you care about in the long term
and this is called a problem of trade
assignment because
uh what's gonna happen right so uh
you're gonna probably
recommend activities to a to a user many
many times before you make any real dent
in their long-term health goals and if
you do or you don't
have a good impact on the long-term
health goals it's not very easy to tell
which of the various activity
recommendations you made to them
was responsible in in moving
uh the needle on the overall goal and
this is a very nasty problem
uh to handle in general and gives rise
to a lot of
hardness of reinforcement learning
nevertheless i hope uh we we
are together in believing that if we
could address these types of challenges
we could enable some cool things
so let's think about why uh
reinforcement learning is hard for just
just a bit longer before i tell you what
can we do about it
like i said there are three challenges
we have generalization we have
exploration and we have this
credit assignment problem and it turns
out if you would like an agent
that can solve all three of them
together
right so is that can sort of um
really solve the intersection of these
problems
it's it's impossible it's it's not like
you you
need somebody really clever who will
come up with a technique to do it
is something that's sort of provably
impossible for anybody
uh to do using a reasonable amount of
data
using a reasonable amount of
interactions with the real world
and the intuition for that is actually
very simple so so let's imagine a
gigantic search tree
okay so so we can we can build a really
deep tree with lots of
lots of leaf leaves
and imagine i told you that there is a
there is a golden path in this tree
so if you take the the golden path you
get a reward of one
every other path if you traverse it you
get a reward of zero for uh reaching the
corresponding leaf node
now of course there's lots lots lot
there's going to be lots and lots of
leaves in this tree if we if we make it
deep
right the number of leaves is
exponentially large in the depth and
if all the nodes are just different from
each other
then basically the only way you find the
the golden path is by trying all paths
in the worst case
right so you will need to sort of
traverse these exponentially many parts
there is nothing that allows you to
collapse them that there is nothing that
allows you to generalize across them
and this is this is a problem that a
hypothetical reinforcement learning
agent which solves the intersection of
these three challenges would be able to
solve
and because this is a this is a problem
we can't hope to solve
the gen the genetic problem of
reinforcement learning is going to be
hard
okay so it was my job to disappoint you
now john is going to actually tell you
that we can we can do something and then
i'll come back
in a bit hello
all right so uh it turns out that there
are various
special cases of reinforcement learning
and those special cases of reinforcement
learning are the places where
we can really hope to create tools that
are of great use
so we're each going to cover some
special cases of reinforcement learning
next
i'm going to start with contextual
bandit learning this is kind of a bread
and butter thing
we started working on contextual bandit
learning in 2007
and at this point we have you know
deployed systems
going to ga at ignite in a week so that
seems really great
so in connection with learning uh
you you have the same kind of setup as
you do for reinforcement learning you
have
some sort of uh observed user state so
that's the context
for contextual bandit learning you have
an activity recommendation that's the
action and then you have the calories
burned that's the reward
right so that's as before your
goal is typically to optimize some sort
of long-term thing
but we're going to we're going to make a
a big assumption here we're going to
assume
that there's no dependence between
events right
so the recommendation that i give you
today
doesn't affect the outcome to the
recommendation that i give you tomorrow
right or the recommendation that i give
to alec doesn't affect
uh the way that i'll behave or your
you'll behave under some other
recommendation so that's a big
assumption
it's obviously not true in many cases
and yet
when it's true or when it's close to
true suddenly
reinforcement only becomes dramatically
more tractable
so um when we're thinking about
reinforcement we're thinking differently
thinking about policies
and this though i want to reemphasize
something that alex said which is that
a policy is uh is a
it's a mapping of features to actions
it could be a neural network it could be
a decision tree
the representation doesn't really matter
when we're thinking about policies we're
thinking about
something which acts in the world it
actually affects
the reward which is observed and it's
it's critical that actually affect the
reward which is observed
or else the learning items for these
things just don't even work
right right so uh
if we're trying to solve contextual
matter learning this kind of two very
key fundamental questions
one of them is how do you collect the
right data
because if you don't collect the data
for different possibilities you're not
going to be able to
solve the problem effectively the other
one is how do you
evaluate the quality of a policy how do
you know when you have succeeded
these are the the two kind of key
questions you need to
answer in order to uh to really make
progress
so for collecting the right data you're
going to have a policy that policy is
going to
take actions in the world and
conceptually you want this policy to do
two different things
you want to exploit
using all the information that it has so
far
to get the best performance that it can
achieve you also want to explore
so it tries other possibilities and
discovers the information necessary
in order to exploit better in the future
so a large number of papers are about
this
explore exploit trade-off right so
you're exporting for performance
you're exploring to discover new things
and now the question is exactly how do
you
best explore so as to
so as to maximize your total performance
over time
and the nature of the best exploration
algorithms is not a simple
epsilon greedy sometimes they export
sometimes i exploit type thing
and each of the best algorithms is more
like i'm going to explore over all the
plausibly best alternatives so that
there's several different things which
could be the best
i don't know which one it is right now
given the information that i have so far
i'm going to explore over those and over
time the set of possibilities kind of
narrows down
until you're acting uh essentially
deterministically so this
explore exploit tradeoff is is very
fundamental it's something that
you need to understand in order to think
about reinforcement learning and in
contextual balance
it's in its most elemental form
now if you have exploration information
this enables
a superpower of sorts so
you can do counterfactual evaluation but
when you're doing counterfactual
evaluation um
you can evaluate policies that you've
never actually deployed
in the real world that seems
like a lot of fun it's like saying
i don't have to do a b test anymore it's
not entirely true
there are many other uses for a b tests
but if you're
trying to do an a b test for the purpose
of optimizing a policy
you're probably much better off using
counterfactual evaluation to optimize it
offline
and then deploying the optimized policy
so i'll give you a sense of what this
means so let's think about
content recommendation so we're going to
try to recommend a
a news story to somebody and see if
they're interested to that
so you have a user that comes to a
website they have some features their
teacher from texas
uh there's a policy which is gonna make
a decision uh maybe they display a space
article
and then the user reads it it's great
uh another user comes they have some
features the engineer from seattle
a policy chooses a food article and they
read it
and this continues so you have an
engineer from seattle who ignores a
space article
another engineer from texas who reads
the space article
and so forth a million times
okay so given this information
later on you'd kind of like to evaluate
a policy
which says uh if it's an engineer
we'll provide a space article and if
it's a teacher we'll provide a food
article
you can look into your data set and you
can go oh yes
i have a bunch of events which agree
with this
right and then you can you can look at
those events and you can see what
fraction of the time
the uh the the
article was read that gives you a value
for the policy
then you can do the same thing with a
location rule suppose we wanted to
display space articles to people from
texas and food articles of people from
seattle
there's some fraction of the time that
the
events which agree with that rule uh
were occurring the data uh and then for
those events
some fraction of the time that you
actually have a a read event
right so you have a reward
okay so this is uh it seems great
this is very much like an a b test in
some sense except you're doing it after
the fact
but there's a trick here the trick is
kind of amazing if you look closely you
see that there's
a single event which is being used for
both
and that would never occur in an a b
test because in a b test you split your
events across the two different
rules two different policies
so it doesn't really matter when you're
at uh the scale of
trying out two rules but if you wanted
to test a million rules or a billion
rules
this is this is a huge thing uh suddenly
you can
you can do that so if you have uh you
have to worry about things like the
variance of your
estimators it turns out that the
relationship is exponential so with the
data for 21ab tests you can evaluate
a billion different rules this is what
enables
uh contextual bandit learning at a
fundamental level
okay so this is this is the intuition
for why counterfactual evaluation works
every event is in some sense exploring
every policy which chooses the action
the degrees that was taken in that event
now in terms of the math you have
some features an action a probability of
choosing that action and then some sort
of observed reward
your goal is to evaluate this policy
so uh one way to do this is take an
empirical expectation of the reward
times an indicator function which is one
when the policy agrees with the chosen
action
and zero otherwise then divide by the
probability
this is mostly intuitive to people
because the a reward big reward is good
it means the the value of estimator is
bigger and you kind of expect to
check for the actions where you agree
your policy agrees with what's observed
the division by the probability is kind
of the fun part
and the interesting thing about that is
you can prove
that it's unbiased
the claim is for any policy
and for any distribution over the
features and a hidden reward
vector expectation of your estimator is
the expected reward of the policy chosen
action
so that division by p is critical in
making this unbiased
because it's unbiased because you have
those very strong for alls
uh you can use this over and over again
so we use this routinely this new
personal personalizer service has this
built in
the kind of actual evaluation i think is
a dramatic improvement in the experience
of a data scientist
trying to solve these problems because
instead of waiting weeks
for an a b test to get some idea of how
good their policy is
they can check in a minute on some held
out data
all right so i'm only sketching the
surface here
tutorial that alec and i did at icml
which has many more details
there's a new personalizer service
there's many contextual banned
algorithms
implemented in vocal wabbit these are
all things you can look at further if
you want more details
all right so um so next up
i'm gonna talk to you about a different
um
way of simplifying the complexity of
reinforcement learning and
uh that's not making
by making an assumption on the structure
of the problem
but by making an assumption about the
type of data that we have access to
and this is the paradigm called
imitation learning so let's go back to
our running example
we have the same three three steps we
saw before
but now we assume access to some sort of
an expert
okay so so imagine that um
you know you you have this app and what
you have is you have a fitness expert
consulting with you
who checks at least for maybe some
fraction of the users
oh tells you oh here's what i would have
done
if i were recommending an activity to
the user based on their long-term goals
right and you you you record this
recommendation
and the rest of the picture is the same
now uh let's think about what such an
expert
might provide us oh uh sorry before i do
that
the other thing i do want to point out
uh while i
call an expert here uh as we will go
through this narrative we
we will sometimes relax an expert to
just be some existing
uh maybe production system that you have
access to which is
not necessarily giving you expert but
um okay not great type of
ideas about what to do okay so so why do
we care about replicating an expert
uh well one idea would be well if i have
access to an expert do i need to
actually do i need to do something
algorithmic even right do i do i need
do i need a policy do i need a model
maybe i can just use the expert
that's true you could but the expert
doesn't scale you could
use maybe the expert across five users
10 users but you cannot really
have the user the expert choosing
recommendations by hand for millions or
billions of users
even if this somehow magically occurred
it's not really feasible to imagine that
an expert can easily personalize
even if they know what's good for you
they might not
even even if they knew exactly what's
good for you given your goals
it's very hard for people to figure out
which recommendations
you you would actually uh accept
right so if the recommendation was
go run a triathlon you might not do it
right so so so it's we have to think
not uh not just about uh what's good for
you but what you're actually likely to
to to to take as a recommendation
and it's very hard to personalize these
things by hand for human
and that creates a often a pretty easy
avenue to improve upon
an expert right but but that's kind of
the
the second reason why we care about
trying to distill the expert down to a
model because
if we could do so then maybe we could
also learn how to
do better than the expert
on the other hand clearly right so the
expert has given us something very
powerful when we were talking about
uh the reinforcement learning problem in
the beginning i said well you you two
you make a choice
you find out about the reward of that
chosen action
and you don't know what would have
happened if you did something else well
if you truly believe in this expert
they just told you what the ground truth
is they just told you this was the right
thing to do in this setting
so you're certainly in supervised
learning land again you could just train
a classifier that tries to predict
the expert's action based on the context
you observed
and you you you make a good prediction
if you match the expert you made a bad
prediction if you don't
right so we've kind of gone back to the
familiar supervised learning land
and basically depending on the
assumptions you make on the expert
assuming access to such data can
basically simplify the need for
exploration or credit assignment or both
right so that's why having access to
such an expert can be quite powerful
okay so how do we leverage these experts
the first idea is basically what i've
already described to you right so
um you you you get some sort of an
expert to consult with you
um you basically have them
uh generate some trajectories trying to
accomplish a task like you know maybe
maybe the expert can
uh fly around a drone for you in some
particular maneuver that you care to
learn
right and you you just record uh the the
the the context that the expert is
generating the actions that they're
choosing in response to those contexts
the next context
that's getting generated and so on so
forth right you you observe that whole
interaction process
you record it you record it many many
times build some sort of a data set
this is like we discussed this is this
looks very much like a
multi-class classification data set
right we have some context we have
possible actions we could have taken we
know the right one we can just shove
this data set into
our favorite supervised learning
algorithm it builds a classifier
and we could reinterpret this classifier
as a policy for a reinforcement learning
agent
seems simple seems something that should
be ready to go
in many cases okay uh
so we have to be a bit cautious um so
this is an experiment that
um stefan ross uh who was
who was a grad student at carnegie
mellon at the time i did
so here's the game of mario
on the left you see an expert playing
they're doing pretty well
they're gonna get a pretty high score in
the game
now you you do this exact classification
uh idea in order to try and imitate the
expert
and um strange things start to happen
the agent gets stuck
the agent uh falls and dies and
all kinds of failures start to happen
that the expert was not experiencing
why does this happen well remember when
we train our classifiers in supervised
learning we don't get hundred percent
accuracy
we definitely don't get 100 accuracy on
text test data
even if we get this thing wouldn't
pause that's kind of disturbing okay i'm
going to go to the next slide
and okay um
right so so we know we make errors in
classification algorithms
right now the moment you make a mistake
the next state might be very diff might
be something you've never seen in your
data before like you didn't
eat the mushroom to get big well that's
the problem because
you were always getting big in in the
expert trajectories
beyond that point and now you don't know
how to act
right so so small errors
at one time step can put you in states
that you never saw in the expert
trajectories at the future time steps
and now you you have a distribution
uh shift problem which is uh usually
called the problem of compounding errors
these small errors can kind of build up
into a
uh into a big future
uh mismatch
this so that that's that makes these
algorithms kind of brittle
and this is a well-known problem that
people have um since
figured out very intuitive and nice ways
to solve so
here i'll just illustrate one of the
simplest ones which is to really
use the article in the loop rather than
just having this one-off access
vr data set to them right so we have we
have this we have
now we we actually start from the agent
which has some
initial policy the agent executes
the the the policy in the environment to
collect some trajectory
gives this trajectory to the expert the
expert tells you well
okay actually if i were finding myself
in these states
that you you generated here are the
actions
denoted by stars that i would have
chosen instead of instead of the ones
you choose
so again this the the agent can
interpret this as a data set
put it into a supervised learner get
some sort of a
policy execute the new policy
get a new data set from the expert now
you have
the the first data set and the second
data set you can take them together
build a build an even better policy and
you can do this many many times
right so what's happening is as the
agent starts to make some mistakes in
imitating the expert
and goes into new states it has the
chance to show those states to the
expert and get them labeled
and in this way as the process starts to
converge you
you kind of learn to imitate the expert
much better
and this very simple idea introduced in
an algorithm called dagger has since
been studied and refined and advanced in
many different ways there's a very nice
tutorial that
john and hal did at icml 2015 which
covers at least uh a good chunk of the
uh state of the art
uh circa 2015 in the area and it
it the research didn't stop in 2015
people have been doing
um a lot of uh work it's still pretty
active
in particular one of the things uh we we
keep seeing a lot of
interesting results around is as i
remarked
the expert doesn't actually have to be
an expert they just have to sort of
um often
help you get to a good enough point and
then you can
from that good enough point learn to
improve upon yourself how best to do
this
it is something that's still being
actively researched
i i've mostly just told told you about
you know we can we can we can try to
build policies
uh from the experts interaction but of
course
watching the expert act also tells you a
lot about the
the rules of the world right the way the
world the world works the the
the underlying laws of physics and um
how um states and how actions
influence future states and so on and
you can you can try to build
uh models of the world to help you do
better in these tasks as well
one of the things that can be sometimes
onerous in limitation learning is right
the expert has to
and so recording a video of an expert
executing a task is pretty easy but if
the expert has to then
sit down and annotate oh this was the
action i took at first step this was the
action i took at second step and so on
that can be
uh pre-owned res or you have to uh
during some
special type of sensing equipment to
capture
in an automated manner their actions
right so one of the
things people try to worry about is
could we just learn from the video
of the expert executing the task where
we get to observe the states
that they are inducing but not the
action labels
and another thing that we can do in
order to again reduce the burden on the
expert
is if we could um basically if the
expert could
somehow communicate ideas to us at a
more abstract level
rather than very very sort of low level
muscle movement type of annotation that
is often assumed here then we could
again
reduce the amount of communication that
has to happen between the agent and
expert by a lot
and this is often studied in the area of
hierarchical limitation learning
but in general having
access to such an expert when you can is
very powerful because it really tries to
it really gets you much closer to
supervised learning land
from reinforcement learning but still
enables the same kinds of
things that a reinforcement learning
agent
can do and now
john will come back and tell you how to
do some
real reinforcement learning really
all right so i want to go back to uh
this hard problem
so you have these three different things
in reinforcement learning that come
together to create a really hard problem
we have
generalization credit assignment and
exploration
so if you think about any pair of these
we actually know how to solve them
fairly well if you think about just
generalization
and credit assignment it's actually
something that
many of the policy improvement style
algorithms or
imitation learning style algorithms can
get out pretty effectively
if you think about exploration and
generalization that's what contextual
bands are doing
right there's no credit assignment
problem there and so the problem becomes
easy we know how to solve that pretty
effectively
it's also the case that if you look at
exploration and credit assignment
so no generalization problem it's it's
easy
so that's that's something which is we
haven't discussed in detail
uh the first uh paper of that sort was
probably the e cubed
rhythm which was in 1999 i think so this
is 20 years ago
and so uh we've known how to solve
the credit assignment problem with
exploration efficiently
for quite a long time it's just that it
doesn't include generalization
it should end up not being very useful
in practice
right so um it's just there's a
possibility
and we're going to get into some very
current research in the sense that
it's not even quite out yet expect to
come out next week
if you have a small number of underlying
states
generating complex observations is it
possible to do
reinforcement learning
because when you when you when you you
look at these mdp learning items they're
working with a relatively small number
of states
maybe if the world is such that there's
a small number of underlying states
we can actually do the learning
even if we need to do generalization as
well
so that's a it's a lot of fun um
all right so let's think about a
particularly hard problem
so i'm going to have uh two initial
start states
which are randomly chosen and then
i'm going to have an action which leads
to two
next states but the one that it leads to
is again random
i'm trying to create a really hard
problem here just to illustrate
what we're trying to solve and then this
other
uh this lower state will have a
different action which
is 50 chance goes to each of these
two different next states so
uncertain outcomes given in action and
then
i'm going to have a whole bunch of
distracting actions which lead to this
third state i'm going to call that the
bad state
even though you actually get
a little bit of reward when you go to
this bad state
right okay so you have
nine actions which lead to the bad state
one action which leads 50 50 to
these two upper states and now i'm going
to repeat this
100 times okay
and and then what i'm gonna do is i'm
going to uh
say ah there's a big reward
in these two good states at the end
okay so now this might seem like a hard
problem to solve
actually claims this is easy to solve
this was solved 20 years ago with the e
cubed algorithm
they could solve this very easily now
the thing which
is a little tricky the extra twist
is that i'm not going to tell you the
states
instead i'm going to have an observation
which
is generated by the states
all of these four observations come from
the same state
it's a stochastic process it's it's
fairly complex
in terms of what is actually observed
you never observe the same
thing twice so you can never reason
based upon oh i saw this before
and therefore i should do this next so
that completely breaks
the e cubed algorithm in all of its
derivative sense
and now the question is how can we
actually succeed
just just to go through things
explicitly um
we have stochastic start state that
breaks a lot of algorithms
we have suggested transitions that
breaks a lot of other algorithms we have
these unfavorable dynamics
so if you act randomly you tend to lose
that breaks a bunch of algorithms
we have these anti-shaped rewards these
rewards
which lead you in the wrong direction
that breaks many more algorithms
we have okay this is a fun one uh
google sparsity so this is 10 to the 100
is the word is google one google
so we have a one in one google chance of
actually
observing a large reward if we act
randomly
right if we detect the uniform randomly
all the way through
so the number of atoms in the universe
is like 10 to the 80.
so it substantially exceeds the number
of atoms in the universe
and then the last thing is is that
generalization is really required you
have to somehow
generalize across your observations in
order to decide what to do
effectively that's all the challenges
that we're going to
want to solve if we're going to be able
to cope with
an arbitrary underlying small state
space
okay so we can try this out on various
common reinforcement learning algorithms
one of these is
advantage actor and okay so we have
about 100
different states going across and you
can see that it's only initially that
there's any visitation
of the upper good states
so um not too surprising if you
understand how these algorithms work
then we can take a look at proximal
policy optimization which is another one
of these
uh common algorithms people try to apply
and again it just visits a few of these
upper good states and then it it is all
bad all the way through
okay so then uh we can search around for
other uh
benchmarks we actually found one which
is non-trivial um
there's this random network distillation
approach which
came out last year and there we can
actually get it to
visit these good states for a good ways
and then
it kind of peters out over time and
again you can't get to the
solution right so there's a new
algorithm
which should be an archive next week
which looks like this it visits
all these states that's that seems like
a lot of fun
if you look at the performance of the
algorithm in terms of how large a
problem it can solve
it can just power through to the the
100 time horizon situation very
effectively
essentially all the other albums we've
tried kind of break
after about horizon 6
except for a random network distillation
which can go up to 25.
so rnd is pretty fun but
but homer is really nailing it hard
so i want to give you a sense of how
this works because i think that
gives you a sense of how you can hope to
succeed
in solving this this very hard problem
directly
so homer is a uh is a
inductive algorithm so we're always
going to be operating in the
horizon 100 situation but we're only
going to be trying to reach
the horizon two states initially and
then the horizon
three and four and so forth up to uh
100.
and what we're going to do is uh we're
going to assume something
inductively we're going to assume that
we have a policy cover which means
this is a set of policies which can
reach
all the states for the previous time
step so we're going to have to
create that for the next time step as we
go through this
iterative process so we're going to
sample
one of these policies uniformly from
this policy cover
and then we're going to uh for h minus
one steps
roll in with this policy and then we'll
act uniform random
for the next step so we this is after h
minus one steps we see
x and then we take an action that's
going to form random
and then we see a next observation x
prime
and then what we're going to do is
corrupt the data
we're going to 50 chance keep what we
observe
with 50 chance swap x prime
with some other x prime that we observed
okay so this seems a little bit funny
but this is this is how we're going to
create
create a an artificial problem
that we're then going to solve the
artificial problem is
predict whether x prime is corrupted
we're going to do this in a little bit
of a funny way so
typically you would say oh i'm going to
just find some function which can
predict
the label which is either 0 or 1 given
x a and x prime instead we're going to
we're going to have to give a little bit
of structure to that so there's going to
be some
p which uses a phi
of x prime and a phi prime on x prime
right um
okay so let's assume we can solve this
problem this is a standard supervised
learning problem it's not too crazy to
try to solve it
assuming we solve it we can look at
all of the values
that phi prime takes in particular we
might want to restrict the range of phi
prime we might want to say 5 prime can
only have
you know 12 discrete values
we're going to define a reward which is
one whenever we achieve that value
right so then
after we've defined this reward we're
going to call this
pstp function which i'm not going to
define for you but basically
what this is doing is saying look i'm
going to use contextual bandits over and
over again
to find a policy which can achieve this
value
and i can guarantee that relatively
easily
uh so this is this creates a policy
which homes to that value of phi
prime
okay and then uh and then once we've
done this for each of the different
values of pi prime
we can create a policy cover by just
grouping together the policies that
we've discovered
and now after we're done we can create a
policy cover for all the different time
steps
and that just return that okay so so i
haven't solved
for a particular external reward
function but once you can
know how to reach all the corners of the
dynamic space
it becomes easy to just find the optimal
policy
using the same technique that we're
talking about here
all right so this is
this is an interesting algorithm it's
kind of illustrating how we can
build up a uh
a representation for an underlying state
space
through these ancillary prediction
problems
and now we'd like to actually know this
is going to work so obviously we created
a really hard problem
but maybe we missed something maybe
there's some other way that um
that you know a problem can be hard
but we can actually make a claim here
i'm going to define a block markup
decision process which essentially says
that
for every x there's a unique s which
generates it
which means that it's possible given x
to predict which the underlying what the
underlying state is
so given the observation you predict
what the underlying state is
and then i'm going to think about oracle
learning i'm assuming that essentially
all the learning problems that i'm
creating the
the regression problem that i created in
in inside the psdp box the contextual
banner problems that i created
those are solved perfectly so let's just
let's not worry about
errors in those right now so if you can
solve these perfectly
then it turns out you can prove that you
can solve
all block mdp problems in
a polynomial time in the number of
states actions and time horizon
so it's not a coincidence that we had
that really nice
visitation of all states that's what
will happen for any block mdb problem
that you happen to create
right and the key thing here this thing
which is very different from a lot of
other
rl algorithms is that this is
independent
of the size of the observation space
and so in particular you could do things
like
concatenate together all the
observations from all the previous time
steps and say that's my observation for
the next time step
that's okay as far as the number of
samples we need
in order to learn effectively
okay so this is this is a new style of
algorithm
this is a very active research area
these are
some of the other people who are
involved in the process
there's a bunch of fun questions we're
trying to figure out
how do we make this to be a more
incremental algorithm
how do we handle continuous states and
actions
how do we handle commentarial states if
we can if we can figure out how to
master these questions
i think this is a new kind of tractable
reinforcement learning
which we can hope to use over and over
again in practice
all right so this gives
this is at the very forefront of what
we're working on in terms of
reinforcement learning
i want to kind of give you a summary so
the first thing i would say is that
reinforcement ring is useful in practice
now
we have this personalizer service out
which is
getting used heavily
[Music]
rl is intractable in general and it's
important to understand that
because right now a lot of tender loving
care goes into
a number of the advanced applications of
reinforcement learning
uh figuring out exactly how to to create
a tractable
island is i think where we're trying to
go
with research right so what are the
natural forms of reinforcement learning
which are tractable
we went through some so no dependence
between events that's contextual bandits
that's good if you have imitation
sources available we have
several ways to use these and that
that's good it's very helpful
if you have these small identifiable
underlying state spaces that's it's
great
it seems like they can put us into a new
regime for solving problems
and maybe there are others if we can
figure out what these other
islands of tractability are that is i
think really the future of reinforcement
learning in real world applications
yeah so is the biggest challenge is
actually the assumption that no
independent
no dependence between events because in
fact
i think they do fit at home yeah i think
there's almost
always some dependence between events
the question is can you neglect that or
not
right right in many cases you can like
uh
the news article that maybe interests
you just is
not related to one that interests you
right so
so that their independence is a
reasonable type of thing
other times it's not so reasonable
and exactly how we solve this
is tricky right
so that that's this one if you have an
expert who can help you
it's also very powerful right and if
it happens to be the case that there's
some sort of small
underlying dynamics then that also ends
up being tractable
right and then maybe there are other
things as well if we can figure these
out
that's that's kind of where the
excitement is where the magic is
yeah so what's it what's the limitation
of small
yeah so uh we're probably nominal
obviously we can handle like a hundred
um
i would say that at 10 000 i would start
really worrying about the
how complex that is
i think there's a lot of room to improve
on the algorithm that i showed you
i mean one way to think about the
limitation is in
units of let's say supervised learning
sample complexity right so
if you needed a certain amount of data
to
solve uh typical classification problems
in a particular domain
and now you take the same domain and you
imagine a reinforcement learning problem
with a small underlying state space
there
it will scale
at least linearly with the size of that
state space so that that's how your
sample
the sample requirement will go up and
now how much data you can collect will
determine like how many states
uh you can handle
other questions yeah the state space of
go
is large yeah so it doesn't
get under any of those tractable yeah so
um
not quite so the first version of go
used imitation learning quite a bit
and i actually thought that was required
but they managed to get away from that
which is very impressive actually so
they
i think what's going on with that
version is
it is the case that if you have a board
and then you have a
slightly different board maybe the
optimal move doesn't change too much
in a number of cases so i suspect
there's something like an almost
continuous structure
not quite continuous it's not quite the
right concept but this is like a
similarity structure between
nearby uh boards which is
extremely helpful the other thing which
goes along with go
is um it just turns out to be the case
that
mini max plays value is often very close
to
random random place value and so they're
using that
very heavily in the process of trying to
solve go right so
it's like they have a pretty decent
expert
available for evaluating
a board position's value
any other questions
all right we'll take a break for about
15 minutes at 10 15
sarva is going to tell us about how to
solve nlp problems
there's these new tools which are coming
out and essentially they're required if
you want state-of-the-art performance
hi this is john lankford um i'm
i want to primarily uh discuss
assumptions around uh reinforcement
learning
but uh i am watching for uh further
questions so
if you have further questions please uh
send them along
okay so one thing which i think is
really important in applying
reinforcement learning
is figuring out which which kind of
reinforcement
you can actually apply effectively
and this is a bit of an art form because
it's almost always the case
that well it is always the case that the
the forms of reinforcement learning are
sort of defined by a set of assumptions
and those assumptions don't exactly
match what your actual application is
so for example it's it's almost out it
is always the case that
the contextual abandoned assumption the
the idea that the action you take
doesn't influence what you observe next
is wrong but nevertheless it's a really
good assumption to make in many
situations because
if it's close to the truth then you can
find a good solution very
efficiently and and so it may not be
the best possible solution in the sense
that if you assumed you had a really
complex reinforcement learning problem
then maybe theoretically if you saw a
trillion examples
you get an even better solution but
because you never actually
see a trillion examples the independence
assumption between events in contextual
balance is very powerful
another version of this is the the
markov assumption right so
if you're assuming that your world is
going to behave going to mark our big
dynamics
where the state and the state alone
determines what
is going to happen next then
you make an assumption assumption is
often true often
untrue or typically untrue
very commonly there is something
exogenous to what you're thinking of is
your state
which does affect what happens next and
if you could effectively model and learn
that maybe you could do better
if you had a trillion samples but you
don't have a trillion samples
and so you want to make simplifying
assumptions
whenever you can so i think the key
thing when you
have a reinforcement learning problem is
you you want to have a lexicon of what
are the simple
kinds of reinforcement learning what are
the ways to solve things well
and then for each reinforcement problem
you want to think about how you can map
towards these
so which assumptions you can make which
means which which concerns you going to
neglect and that gives you a way to
solve the problem
effectively
okay so uh there was one last question
in uh in the live
feed which is where we can follow things
in
more detail so uh
archive is always a great place we can
post all of our papers on archive
i also pointed them to the reinforcement
learning group web page where we
usually have some amount of recent
information yeah
another place where things appear now
and then is on my blog which is
hunch.net
h-unch.net
are there other questions we should try
to answer yeah so so i guess one thing i
wanted to
uh a few people ask this regarding
our activity recommendation example that
we used as the ring one
and uh in particular i think uh with
regards to the contextual bandit set up
there
uh which is uh whether we
like how do we think about
personalization in those settings
whether we are learning a separate model
per user
or we are learning something more global
and um and basically the answer
really comes down to a few factors right
so
so we know that we are going to require
some amount of data before we can start
making meaningful decisions and
[Applause]
do we want to wait and receive that
amount of data from
each individual user before we start
doing something meaningful for them
in most settings the answer is
not we might not even see that much data
from each
individual user and you want to have
a paradigm where actually your system
kind of improves for everyone the more
users you have
for the application so with that in mind
we have usually taken the approach of
featurizing
the users and the features can include
some unique
user specific features like user ids or
something so that
each user still has a slice as a model
but we we generally do try to learn a
joint model
and also optimize joint performance
across
all users typically via an average
there's another question that just came
in do you think that a big problem with
applying rl to real world problems is
that it is not as accessible
to analysts working in commercial
environments it's simply not as simple
to model
a problem as it would be to throw some
data into a ml python package
do you think it is the responsibility of
researchers to reach out and improve
the accessibility by education and
software or will this naturally catch up
if it can be shown to be effective to
more problems
so i certainly believe there's a huge
gap in
the tools that are available for doing
reinforcement learning compared to the
tools that are available
for doing supervised learning now
the the nature of the tools for
reinforcement learning i think
inherently often needs to be different
than from the nature of the tools
used for supervisors so in supervised
learning you're sort of
used to downloading the data on your
computer and just
partying on it right but in
reinforcement learning
it's actually pretty critical that you
have a high fidelity
i've often found that attempts to do
reinforcement learning fail
because the vlogging is not high enough
quality and so reinforcement tends to be
very dependent upon the quality of the
logging
and that means that it's very important
you have
a high quality logging system
furthermore if you're doing
reinforcement against a live system you
never actually get all the data you're
just
you're interacting with the live system
and you're learning from those
interactions as you go so there's
this maybe we should think about this as
two different modes for reinforcement
mode one is where you have a simulator
instead of a data set
and you're trying to do reinforcement
learning in that simulated environment
mode two is where you're you're
doing reinforcement learning with actual
interactions with the real world
so mode one is a little closer to
supervised learning but you're working
with simulators rather than data sets
mode two you're working with data sets
but it's more of a data source rather
than data set
and that means that the nature of the
tools that you need are different
now as far as who has responsibility
well i think that
um i am happy to take responsibility
for creating reinforcement running tools
and we are actively working on this as
vocal weapon is an open source project
uh
everybody is welcome to contribute to it
this is uh
the key algorithms behind the
personalized service which i
talked about in the uh in the
presentation in the webinar
this is a suite of
tools and algorithms which you can use
actively
to get things done
so um i mean the the other thing i
wanted to add was
there is definitely a gap in the
maturity of things
available for supervised learning and
reinforcement learning but that also
partly just reflects the maturity
the relative maturity of algorithms in
the two fields like
supervised learning definitely has
become much closer to turnkey in that
you can hope to stick some data into an
algorithm and
get something somewhat sensible out of
it in most cases
and um as we were as we were discussing
through a good bit of the presentation
reinforcement learning does require a
lot more uh
care and thought in exactly how you pose
a problem and what
what problem structures are uh
tractably solvable and so on and
and that part makes it a bit harder to
to to to have general purpose tools out
there because those tools will have
their limitations and
part of it again can be has to be
addressed by education which is um
again something we are trying to do
through for instance webinars like this
here's another question you've talked a
bit about the independence between
events assumption but what about the
scenario where the mdp assumption
itself is not necessarily accurate are
there any steps i can take to ensure
that my algorithms still perform well in
this case
actually pretty interesting so there are
algorithms which are a little bit more
robust against breakdowns in the mdp
assumption
so there's sort of policy improvement
algorithms
which are essentially deciding based
upon your observations what to do
and those observations are not actually
capable of summarizing everything
they'll still do the best they can
uh without giving the the the
information that they have
so so that family of algorithms i think
does have a little bit more robustness
against a breakdown of the mdp
assumption yeah so it really comes down
to
uh you know what are the ways in which
we are trying to leverage the markov
property of the environment like
uh if you are trying to build a
full-on dynamics model of the world um
and we only we we assumed
that a particular formulation state is
markovian and try to predict the next
state using it and if this turns out to
be false then we have a lot bigger
problems then
if we just rely that we can
you know express good policies using a
certain representation of state
or express good value functions using a
um so so you you have to choose the
algorithms carefully there
there's another question in many
commercial applications there's a large
lag in observing the reward
eg waiting for an approval for a sale
are there general tactics for mitigating
problems caused by this reward
this is actually a very interesting
topic because
the problem the thing which makes
reinforcement running difficult is not
actually
a lag in the reward you can have
a reward which is delayed by a year and
as long as you knew
exactly which action led to that reward
uh
it would be still a relatively
straightforward problem to solve
contextual bandit style formulation
so um well there are two things it
should also be that when you
actually incorporate that information a
year later it is still meaningful so
that's true
the world has not completely changed
it's true but but typically if there's a
long delay then
yeah i it seems like the world is not
changing too fast
um the thing which makes reinforcement
running really hard is when you have
several different actions that you take
before you observe a reward
so if you're in that situation you're in
a much more
delicate hard to solve problem and
okay so the the there's three approaches
that we discussed
one approach is with textual dentists
you form a short-term proxy for your
long-term reward
and then you just ignore the fact that
it's not your long-term reward and solve
a short-term proxy reward
another approach is you have some
reference algorithm which guides you
through
the sequence of possibilities and you
try to improve on that respect to your
long-term reward
and the third approach is is more like
the the last
particularly advanced algorithm i
discussed where you are
trying to you're assuming that there's
some underlying state space that
is latent that is relatively small and
you're
actively discovering the dynamics of the
of the world
in order to efficiently uh learn a
policy
um so so i wanted to take another one
from the recent questions which is
what are the things to keep in mind
while formulating an environment all by
ourselves for solving the problem and
this kind of
uh uh at least the way i view it hinting
to
uh the more general question that when
we are setting up um
kind of an abstract problem when we
qualify codify it into
reinforcement learning problem and
define exactly what we mean by state and
action
uh rewards uh what is the problem
horizon and so on there are several
design choices involved here
and certainly we have to be quite
careful in that some of those will make
the problem
significantly more or less tractable to
solve
so in particular one thing people
worry about a lot in reinforcement
learning is how to define the reward
right and as you've seen the rewards
have kind of delicate semantics
in that you you you have a reward that
you can optionally observe at each time
step
but then we have to make sure that
overall
in a trajectory the rewards aggregate uh
to our to reflect our long-term goals
to reinforce desirable behaviors over
time and this can be quite tricky to do
if not done well this can lead to all
kinds of pathologies there are
weird examples like you have uh you're
trying to design a vacuum cleaner you
give it a reward for picking up dust and
it learns to
pick up dust dump it pick up dust and so
on to to get infinite reward right so we
have to be very careful in defining the
uh the right reward function sometimes
people again try to
infer the reward function using
demonstrations and so on this this field
is called inverse reinforcement learning
sometimes we can simplify obviously the
problem a lot down
if uh we can get away with just
formulating it as a contextual banded
problem then
uh at least uh we don't have to worry
about uh the long-term semantics of the
rewards
but even there the the precise numerical
encoding of the rewards can make a huge
difference
and this is something we go into in more
detail in the
uh tutorial that that is uh
linked here under the additional
resources so if you're interested in
looking more into reward formulations
that that may be a good
good place to look as well and the other
part is exactly how should we think
about representing
state and there may be a good rule of
thumb to think about
is uh i mean effectively in most
problems
uh we are you know casting the state
uh using some sorts of features um
and uh they can be the similar types of
features that you would use
in solving a supervised learning task in
the same domain
right so when people are using um
reinforcement learning tasks where the
observations are visual
they usually would use a similar
featurization of the similar encoding
for the image that
they would use in a uh typical computer
vision setting
uh maybe we augment it uh
to uh to to to contain a bit about the
the the past trajectory but
uh but but but the state you can think
of uh yeah
similar features as you would have in a
supervised learning task
another question here it appears human
learning involves conceptualizing
subtasks generally useful across
contexts
towards achieving a goal hardcore rl
seems to capture this to some extent
nevertheless
actually most things upstream seem hand
engineered
like providing a pool of goals and
subtasks your thoughts on approaching
this problem so we can leverage the
power of composition
so uh i think it's actually a
fascinating research area
you're absolutely right that most people
who are looking at this
are kind of uh hand crafting sub goals
that uh that you work with and that if
you're in a situation you're just trying
to solve a reinforcement learning
problem it's actually a
very sound strategy in many ways
nevertheless it is really appealing to
try to
create these sub goals automatically
and i don't i don't have a good general
purpose algorithm for this
but i would say that the homer algorithm
actually does
have this structure to some extent it's
uh it's creating
uh subtasks of reaching each state on
its frontier of
explored sub export area
and then it's it's using that subtask
repeatedly
to gather new information so as to
advance the frontier
of where it knows to how to explore
effectively
one last question enjoyed this webinar
in a previous question it was mentioned
that there is no general guarantee on
convergence
to global optimal policy does there
exist a guarantee of conversion
stability boundedness to a local optimal
policy
i mean i guess uh for policy
improvement methods you can but
you have a snake in the box like
examples
so the problem is that local convergence
can still take exponential time there's
scanner examples which show that it
it can take it into that number only for
uh that's only for the one
one step right so i'm thinking if you
literally
did a policy gradient type algorithm
right so think about uh
you're doing policy improvement over a
hundred time steps
yeah and you
improve in one dimension yeah and then
you can prove
another dimension and now maybe you have
to go back to the previous dimension to
improve
and again and again and again and again
for each of the different dimensions
so the number of times you might have to
improve in a dimension in order to reach
the global optima
it could be very but you're not global
so for
for local but it's even though it's a
local optima
right it's i mean i it's very easy
because
it's uh it's just uh at the end
it's just a smooth optimization problem
and it's we are we are getting unbiased
gradient testament so proving
uh at least like if everything in the
environment is regular enough that
the objective is smooth as a function of
the policy parameters
then you will you will find a stationary
okay you will find a stationary point
yes okay i think the last problem is is
a
yeah yeah yeah right so in that case the
global optimum is the local optimize
yeah so the tricky thing is you will
find a stationary point but it can be a
saddle point
yeah i think the answer is no
unfortunately um so for
general reinforcement learning it is
often very intractable
uh you can often improve on your current
uh solution
that's relatively tractable um you can
test to see if there's a quick
improvement on your current solution
with
variability but they'll be small
deviations if you're in
in contextual balance then uh it's
roughly easy to get the global optima
if you're in more general reinforcement
learning
it gets tough
um you want to read the question
yes so we have a question saying is it
much harder to obtain our
algorithms with good regret guarantees
meaning that they have good performance
along the learning path
versus good final policy expected return
guarantees or are the two objectives
more or less equivalent
so i guess it depends a little bit on
the precise setting
so in the in the tabular settings where
bulk of the
the theoretical work has happened there
is actually
um there is a paper
from christoph dan uh and emma bronskill
uh and uh total artimor which basically
uh provides like a unifying uh
way to get both back and
regret um
for um in general um
we have uh there is not in most settings
where we have
uh one or the uh one guarantee of one
kind we expect to get guarantee of the
other kind as well
so i would say they are mostly
comparable in difficulty
they want us to wrap up so thank you all
for uh
listening in
you